uneducated poorly informed disrespectful
bankers not things you'd like to think
were associated with one of the UK's
elite education establishments yet
pupils from a student union at Cambridge
University have voted not to support a
motion calling for the commemoration of
Remembrance Day claiming it glorifies
war amending emotion activists want to
abolish is anything to do with British
War veterans Remembrance Day and even
the poppy to me this illustrates just
our education system is failing by
letting slip basic values and standards
respect understanding and gratitude are
all completely missing from the modern
day curriculum generations of brave men
and women some in their teams have
afforded these young people the Liberty
they now flaunt
if I could teach these wayward
miscreants one lesson it would be that
there has never been peace unless it was
fought for their freedom has been paid
for with the blood of the brave
understand that war is not glorious but
our dead are you you can't help but
respect what you said Phil and let me
add one extra point to your argument
which is that the Poppy Appeal last year
raised forty six point six million
pounds for good causes particularly
disabled veterans lay there aiming for
50 million this year and I hope that
they get it I certainly be buying a
poppy but your underlying point you
can't have it both ways you can't say
that this is a kind of insult to British
value is the most fundamental of which
is free speech and then tick them off
for expressing therefore their freedom
of speech this is not the first time in
Saturn you're you're under fifty so
you're far too young to really have this
as a kind of reference back in nineteen
thirty three the Oxford Union Society
the debating society Oxford and actually
Cambridge
debated a motion that said that motion
was this house will not will fight for
king and country and that both Cambridge
and Oxford defeated that
it was a tremendous scandal Churchill
wrote later that he thought it
encouraged the Germans and Japanese to
believe that we would not fight but I
think you cannot say that those young
people who by the way many of them did
actually go and fight should not have
the right to express that or be ticked
off forsaking the view which was I think
a valid and legitimate though wrong
pacifist position yeah I think that
their view and this is this was the
underlying point that I made is that
their view it's not based on they're not
educated properly they don't given you
freedom of speech as you keep battering
on about it's based on on what you what
you're taught and what your growing up
with okay and like they say basic values
are missing there just doesn't seem to
be there any men just disagree with you
I introduced some people who definitely
understand the context you're talking
about because they are veterans
themselves and this is a this is a clip
from veterans for peace and what they
think about it every Remembrance Sunday
we veterans for peace walk to the
Cenotaph in London under the banner
never again as a reminder of what has
gone before
and with a determination that never
again with our children or future
generations inflict on others or
experience themselves the horror and
pity of war the reality is feel that
there are people who have liked you for
in Wars and been willing to make that
sacrifice who now are also worried that
the poppy is sending the wrong message
and they're not against remembering
those who fought they're saying they
want to prevent further Wars I
personally I wear a poppy I wear and
poppy and I choose to remember that but
I really want to add what trevor has
been saying which is that the one of the
sacrifices that I so appreciate that men
and women who died made was for us to
have the freedom to express the views
and the conscience we have and so while
I were a poppy I think that puppy would
be meaningless if I were wearing it on
to jail let me just say right war is
hideous and I've been in several war
zones myself ok as it is and I won't
bestow upon anybody ok at all in any way
shape or form but unfortunately
unfortunately nowadays you know it
forced upon us left right and center
where we have to go to war okay so were
these in their ideal world we'd all
Woodall skip around merrily and there'd
be no more Wars and I'd love that that'd
be great I'll be out of a job but it
would be great okay that's not a real
world so these people these students and
not living in the real world they're
living out of what they've read in books
it's not based on anything other than
what they've been taught in school
because remember we stop telling me I
don't know but it's not a perfect world
have we been involved in Wars we should
have course we've been but there are
some times please the classic is the
Falklands conflict that they had no
choice but to go to war in that's it and
I respect that the ex-servicemen greater
than I am the man and he's entitled to
his views and I do get the idea that
people who fought in world war ii and
indeed world war one did it so that
people have the freedom i don't like the
fact the way that the student have acted
in cambridge and just to broaden it out
briefly and to bring in which i think is
probably the most poignant clip I've
seen since I've been working the
pleasure bringing in just a second there
are students in Kent University now who
has taken a vote that you're not allowed
to wear sombrero or cowboy boots and
fancy dress party because that's culture
appropriation misappropriate I make the
point because these people are of an age
that a hundred years ago they were
laying down their lives they were going
over the top that means shot at by
Germans and various others and this week
just this week has been released the
most extraordinary footage from they
shall not grow old restored World War
one footage by Peter Jackson these are
the lot sort of lads they had no choice
because so generate so isolated living
through this mud just the same as a
rabbit you knew what was going on within
your vision beyond the human
[Music]
you live that trance you didn't polish
any buttons you wore any you like nobody
worried all they were concerned with
effective fight these lads these lads
had plenty they won't worry about
sombreros or cowboy boots they weren't
about getting a bullet in the brain
that's the truth so monumentally unfair
why it's monumentally on fly well the
clip you just shot saw there was of
young men who'd gone to war many of them
and we know this from their Diaries in
war poets went to war and they hated it
and they thought it was wrong Lions led
by donkeys remember so I think it's so
unfair to say that somebody who says we
don't think that this we should think of
war in this particular way and we
shouldn't remember it in a particular
way is somehow should be given as they
used to say in the old days the white
feather or is an idiot with sombreros I
think that's really unfair
young people eyes only but they're
serious I see we should hear from
someone so this is the chair of the
Cambridge University the is Tamara
coffee and let's listen to what he says
I've noticed that not many students at
all will wear poppies around the
Remembrance Day period and we wanted to
change that and raise as much money for
our veterans charities and raise
awareness on this important issue much
to our surprise the motion was
overwhelmingly rejected by the council
on the grounds that it might be
offensive to international students it
is the chair of the Conservative
Association the University just need to
make that conserve just to make it very
clear no thank you
and so that is what frustrates me so the
reason that motion was not passed is
because it might be offensive to
international students I don't
understand that why we live in this
world where we are so afraid to offend
people because if an international
student wishes to take offense take
offense so what that's your choice
because when you actually look at what
the poppy what the poppy represent so
this is from the British Legion they say
that to them the Brit the poppy
represents the sacrifices and
contributions our armed forces community
have
made in the defense of freedom now to me
that is fundamentally important and it
is something that you should be
respecting I'm thankful for and grateful
for and to see it actually we're not
going to show that gratitude because we
might offend somebody over there I
couldn't care less about offending me
the last word we will get will get will
give out Barb's a shell Bob's what
you're saying up what would you say to
those who don't want to wear a papi like
it there's a sophisticated proper answer
right well that's nearly it for this
week but before we go there's just time
for this because there's no shortage of
advice for members of the Tauri cabinet
at the moment with everybody piling in
to offer their views on what ministers
should do about brexit but there's one
person whose advice was rather different
from the rest this is what Michael
curves wife Sarah vine had to say about
Theresa Meers words on last week Sandra
Marcia she is tenacious she is calm she
just can't does plow on I mean I think
it would be quite nice if all the men
stopped shouting and screaming and
waving their Willie's around and maybe
just gave her a bit of a hand
occasionally indeed gentlemen put those
willies away and for that diplomatic
advice Sarah you are a straight talker
of the week